[Musique]
nous avons beaucoup de sujets abordés
dans ce numéro de paf
et pour le faire heureusement il ya
internet bezina bonjour fait décoller
oui c'est vrai comment ça marche bien
déjà très bien très bien alors vous
enseignez toujours le dos droit rien n'a
changé sur les sciences politiques
oui oui oui donc tout va bien vous de
choses à dire et on va parler justement
de la situation des étudiants est ce
qu'elle est aussi dramatique qu'on ne le
pensez vous de lire
et on en parlera aussi avec stéphane
mensonge à patrick donc je vous dis
toujours professeur à l'université de
droit 2 saint quentin versailles saint
quentin en yvelines paris saclay toi
toute simplicité
voilà à touba par existants de la
situation de l'université des étudiants
notamment mais il ya aussi toute une
situation sociale importante à aborder
on va en parler au cv jean charles
lajoie dit bonjour de toujours éditeurs
personne ne changent de métier au fond
dans cette heure tant que ça dure aide
les gens lisent des livres toujours donc
mais vous ne serez jamais le passé
jamais jamais aucune décision ferme est
ferme et définitive
non on enterre jamais le passé c'est le
c2
le dernière publication c'est bien de
qui vient de sortir de nicolas la
tunisie alors c'est un roman vous devrez
vous devriez adorer enfin comme tous les
autres d'ailleurs je sais que vous êtes
fanatique mais celui-là c'est un roman
garantie sans gilet jaune sans voile
sans donc ça fait plaisir un peu une
bulle et travailler une histoire assez
classique mais très drôle écrit de façon
très cinématographique par un jeune
jeunes auteurs qui y en a sous le pied
comme on dit c'est son premier roman
non c'est 2e 2e 2e mais c'est le
meilleur ce qu'il est chez nous dit que
la duplessis à 10 pc on n'en perd jamais
le passé ce qui c'est vrai est ce qu'on
enterre d'ailleurs le passé puisqu'il ça
fait un an que la crise des gilets
jaunes commencé et on voit aujourd'hui
une situation sociale très émouvant très
très difficile avec cette idée peut-être
que balla la france est en train
d'échapper au pouvoir emmanuel macron on
va voir ce grand mouvement là sncf
notamment à partir du 5 décembre mais il
ya aussi la grève dans les hôpitaux mais
il ya aussi la situation dans les
universités
peut-être qu'on va commencer par ce
mouvement prévues du 5 décembre à
beaucoup de gens disent ça va être un
tournant pour le quinquennat c'est là
qu'on va voir s'il va résister ou pas si
les grèves vont prendre ou pas qu'est ce
que qu'est ce qu'ils veulent et oui je
me suis je suis catastrophé mais je suis
quand même un peu optimiste j'espère que
ça va être beaucoup moins fort et
beaucoup moins
[Musique]
catastrophique pour la france qu'on peut
on peut le craindre
parce que bon il ya quand même beaucoup
de gens qui ne sont pas cheminots qui ne
sont pas l'air atp qui ne prennent pas
leur retraite à 53 ou 54 ans et qui vont
peut-être en avoir ras-le-bol au site
est prise en otage permanente et de dire
bon jeu il faut quand même que les
choses changent de la main à un moment
il faut quand même arrivé à réformer un
peu ce un peu ce pays et c'est donc il
ya peut-être un moment les la raison va
l'emporter
que dire alors on va nous parler de la
clause du grand père ça c'est très bien
peut-être c'est une porte de sortie pour
le gouvernement c'est très bien pour les
retraites il faut il va bien falloir que
ces régimes change enfin j'ai bien ça on
peut pas rester comme ça séparés
totalement aberrant qu après tout le
monde essaye de s'agglomérer assez à ses
revendications fait d'ouvrir du tout
pourquoi les étudiants et reste collé
avec les gens de la ratp de la sncf
si le souci d'aider des étudiants
maintenant c'est leur retraite enfin à
18 ans est catastrophique on peut le
penser
justement est ce que on verra ce que ça
donne mais est-ce qu'on exagère pas
peut-être pas le le le les conséquences
de ce mouvement en oubliant quand même
que ça concerne le public qui n'est pas
toute la france il ya deux privés plutôt
pas gréviste pas revendicatif non vous
me regardez vous agace
en dix ans la république
bien sûr le service le faire les scpi
bien si c'est vrai c'est assez
particulier celle à 7 cm je l ai dit pas
si ces facteurs le cercle service public
il est évidemment beaucoup plus visible
au regard en tout cas de ses services
publics la qui pour l'instant son temps
partiellement du moins en situation de
monopole et qui ne met enfin ça ne
durera pas avec des situations qui jean
charles sur le fond a raison avec des
situations qui ne peuvent pas rester en
l'état au regard de multiples paramètres
qui eux évoluent changement de la durée
de vie le caractère moins pénible que
jadis de certaines de certaines tâches
le bon le le conducteur de train mais de
moins en moins de charbon dans le dans
la chaudière et encore c'était pas le
conducteur qu'il qu'il y mettait alors
ça a évolué depuis il faut pas non plus
exagérer aussi dans l'autre sens
mais je alors il ya aussi une agrégation
politique jean charles parlait des
étudiantes sert alors sont pas toujours
ce sont certains étudiants certains
mouvements étudiants et pas d'autres il
ya eu une agréable qu convergent
géologique maintenant il ya des français
qui pensent que en effet le mouvement va
continuer vincent ollivier et il ya même
une majorité de français qui pensent
cela mais est ce que c'est ce qu'ils ont
raison de le processus de vente de ses
la question de la représentation et du
paysage politique d'aujourd'hui qui ne
reflète pas exactement pas encore l'état
l'état de l'opinion et d'une manière
encore plus profonde
là comment dirais-je le le paysage le
paysage philosophique politique
français il n'y a pas en miroir une
représentation qui se conforte la voilà
la social démocratie a disparu
l'opposition d'aujourd'hui c'est d'un
côté les populistes nationalistes et de
l'autre l'extrême gauche
donc ce sont a priori deux ensembles
keane qui à l'origine en tout cas ne
n'était pas vouée à gouverner pas des
anciens partis de gouvernement
et il ya donc une un gap qui me
semble-t-il est assez assez préoccupant
ce point de vue c'est ce que pour moi
celui csii à rennes n'y a pas de
d'évacuation du conflit va devoir n'y a
pas de transformation de cellules
seulement sociale dans le discours
politique c'est c'était un peu
d'ailleurs ce qui avait fait la force
des villes rend la force et la faiblesse
des idées jaune d'ailleurs c'est à dire
qu' il ait pas de 10,6 politique
je me demande si ce mouvement est
vraiment le bon pour justement cette
manifestation sociale moi j'ai tendance
à penser est une grève des cheminots une
grève de la sncf c'est un euphémisme en
quelque sorte et que donc bon ça va ça
va suivre son cours mais je suis pas
certaine que ça soit l'ampleur des actes
26 34 des gilet jaune qu'on a pu avoir
l'année dernière parce que justement la
force des gilet jaune c'est d'avoir été
complètement inopinés c'est à dire que
nous allons les écraser
voilà et j'ai l'impression que au
contraire quand c'est organiser les
mouvements sociaux même qu'avait voulu
organiser jean luc mélenchon au moment
des ordonnances tout tout tout ces
révoltes dont on entend trop parlé à
l'avance à mon avis sont pas forcément
celles qu'il faut le craindre le plus
donc je suis pas certaine que ça amène à
la révolution escompté quant au fond
totalement d'accord sur la nécessité du
changement on peut pas continuer comme
ça économiquement et pas seulement
économiquement
voilà des données évoluent on
dis donc après je crois quand même qu'on
est dans une france du petit pré carré
il n'y a qu'à regarder le nombre de
niches fiscales en tâtant parlait de ça
parce que c'est intéressant mais c'est
vrai qu'il quand on parle du 5 décembre
évidemment ce qu'ils qui la comparaison
avec laquelle on regarde ça c'est
c'était la situation de 95 avec là où la
population alors avait avait suivi et
approuvé le mouvement est ce qu'on est
en question est ce qu'on est encore en
95 bah surtout en 95 avait quand même
quelques revendications alors que là il
n'y a rien eu une sorte de ras-le-bol
plus ou moins mal exprimé c'était aussi
même genre de réformes
tout autour de ronds-points conception
parce qu'ils ont certainement parce que
les gens veulent on sait pas qui sont ce
pas
c'est presque 6 me non c'est un oui mais
non les cheminots de parler d'aidé
quand je parle de 95 c'était en effet le
service public qui avait été suivi par
une grande majorité de l'opinion voilà
mais c'est pour ça que tout à l'heure je
parle se parler de la cause du grand
père c'est probablement parce qu'ils qui
va hélas arrivé c'est à dire que ça
reporte la vraie réforme à n'en plus de
45 ans parce qu'on va dire seulement les
gars qui rentre à 19 ans 20 ans les cff
alors lui lui il aura une retraite comme
les autres voilà mais ça fait est ce que
est ce que franchement là
l'état et la france être quoi payer
encore ses déficits qui s'accumulent la
sncf à la ratp ou pillées ces retraites
pendant 45 ans à un pari fou pièce que
ce que les gens vont le supporter est ce
que les gens du secteur primé est ce que
tous les autres on va dire maintenant
mais qu'est ce que c'est que ces
privilèges qu'ils restent ici justement
voyez ce qui n'est pas demander aux purs
entreprises c'était la réforme des
régimes spéciaux qui avait fait qu'on en
était arrivée dans la rue en 95 c'était
quasiment le même point d'across né au
moins je suis pas sûr qu'on soit
complètement dans la même donne
notamment par rapport à la réforme elle
même qui a quand même été peut-être un
petit peu mieux a mené dans l'opinion et
il faut savoir que moi j'ai passé
l'homme c'est qu'on ne sait pas très
bien ce que cette réforme c'est parce
que ça veut dire essayer de travailler
pour notre mission et dieu sait si si ce
jeu est une travailleuse bien mais je
trouve qu'on ne trouve rien ne s'est pas
très bien le projet de loi est
totalement ben c'est pas si la
pérennisation des entre les régimes
c'est celle d'un régime universel mais
profondément ça ne veut rien dit j'ai
justement eu deux grandes volonté de
technocratie en france et qui qui arrive
un peu la première c'était le
prélèvement à la source et la deuxième
c'est ligne ification des régimes de
retraite et au fond est ce que les
français sont attachés à leur régime
particulier ceux qui bénéficient peu
désavantagés par visé envie d'arriver
dans le droit commun est ce que est ce
que c'est une bonne idée finalement de
vouloir l'égalité de tous
est-ce qu'on n'est pas plutôt de régime
comme ça où chacun a son petit pré carré
ses petits avantages et où finalement
tout le monde est à peu près satisfait
financièrement ça tient pas c'est tout
c'est mais c'est juste ça fasse un peu
c'est un peu pâti en place et le peuple
pourquoi est-ce qu'on continuerait à
subventionner le régime des retraites
delà de la ratp ou de la sncf
il n'y a aucune raison mais les médecins
sont pas très satisfaits de devoir
donner ce qu'ils ont cotisé à d'autres
caisses de retraite par exemple
mecelec sauf que les avocats de 7 5 août
par un centime à la collectivité puisque
c'est un régime autonome qui fonctionne
je veux dire il récupère de la régie
global
non mais on peut comprendre que eux ils
disent ok nous on se bat on fait notre
petit truc on se débrouille on demande
rien à personne
ok ça c'est concevable si si demain la
ratp ou la sncf les cheminots et disent
ok on va se débrouiller tout seul on
vous demande de rien on va cotiser ce
qu'on veut on distribuera ça ne coûtera
rien aux autres alors là chacun fait ce
qu'il veut très bien ça c'est
respectable mais c'est pas envie moi de
payer pour la retraite du cheminot plus
que pour la mienne ça veut dire que je
ne vois c'est ça me paraît insensé c'est
insensé que c'est quand même le
fonctionnement même du système de
retraites c'est qu'on n'est pas dans un
système de capitalisation par points ou
en finance salle propre entraînement on
est dans un lycée pierre de dire
justement qu'on est dans un système de
solidarité donc normalement on ne
finance pas notre propre qu'est ce donc
sortir tout seul atome et l'individuel
ça fait quand même partie du deal
au départ donc ces commerçants la
bascule que si on fait ça et jaffe prêt
à payer la retraite des cheminots six le
cheminot prend là sa retraite en tant
que la mienne
ben c mais c'est tout mais s'il apprend
dix ans avant non je veux on n'a pas
l'argent pour le faire donc arrêtez de
penser que l'on aurait de l'argent pour
tous c'est lui c'est le vrai problème
c'est ça le problème de la société et on
peut toujours dire on en reparlera pts
tout à l'heure les bourses pour les
étudiants veut pas donner des bourses à
tous les étudiants donc on veut pas
payer des retraites en or à tout le
monde et dire à tout le monde peut-être
ça serait idéal que tout le monde prenne
sa retraite à 50 ans des gens qui
seraient ravis
on ne peut pas le faire financièrement
c'est tout suis je suis d'accord sur le
principe de ne pas ne pas avoir de micro
avantage qui se multiplient néanmoins
moi je suis pas sûr que ce soit vraiment
ça qui cause le déficit actuel de la
sécurité sociale de tous les comptes
publics
je crois qu'on est quand même assez loin
du compte
deux facteurs qui ont droit
l'international y instaure le régime est
pas en difficulté financière
c'est dans l'avenir que de toute façon
ça sera pas jouable rapport à
l'allongement de la durée de vie par
rapport à ce système de peut-être même
ce système solidaire qui doit peut-être
s'arrêter parce qu'on continue à
financer dans le vide et que ça ça ne
sera pas tenable sur l'avenir néanmoins
mois sur la question des petits prés
carrés ce qui me gêne un petit peu c'est
justement ce principe d'égalité c'est
qu'on essaye de tous ou vouloir la même
chose en permanence et à la fin on est
pourtant attaché à avoir quelque chose
de totalement différent de son voisin à
chaque fois donc il ya quand même des
dogmes assez contradictoire dans la
volonté des français que moi j'arrive
pas forcément à comprendre et y'a qu'à
regarder la somme de niches fiscales je
crois qu'on l'a 457 pour cette année
pour les pour les foyers fiscaux
particuliers je suis pas sûr qu'on
puisse continuer mais sarkozy est elle
vous voyez bien la réaction belle parce
que c'est vrai que c'est il ya aussi
devant l'autre comme ça type lui qui
partait d'un bon sentiment mais quitte
quand même une peut-être une volonté
technocratique de tout unifié de au fond
d'elle le vieux débat entre la france
jacobine de la france girondine on leur
trouve souvent non je tournais pas ces
femmes which way ça s'est un peu donnez
moi c'est un peu caricatural c'est un
perron d'un jacques notamment en force
le trait mais vous avez raison de ces
pédagogique
non moi je nature jacobine oui mais ce
succès c'est que c'est pour ça oui mais
ceci posé jeu
ils ont peut pas enfin un système
uniforme pour tous c'est de toute façon
pas possible parce que les situations
sont très différentes
marino situation à nous on n entrons sur
le marché du travail extrêmement tard et
d'ailleurs les régimes de retraite de la
fonction publique je vous avoue que
pourquoi prendre en considération les
six derniers mois et pas les 25
dernières années
je ne sais pas je t'aime six derniers
mois pour oui c'est très favorable alors
peut-être parce que l'on rentre très
tard mais c'est pas le cas de tous les
fonctionnaires
nous terminons tard je notre durée de
travail va s'allonger ses 65 ans
aujourd'hui ce sera 67 dans pas
longtemps
et puis c'est parfois pour certains
d'entre nous jusqu'à 68 69 ans et je
trouve ça parfait il ya encore des cd
décider sinon ça serait bien mais ce qui
est ce qui ce qui est bien c'est que
celle que ça se peut oui c'est que chez
nous la sélection jamais totalement
dehors on les fait revenir non mais dans
les divertir tu plutôt intellectuelle
oui on a pas on ne peut pas forcé
d'arrêter à 60 ans non la plupart du
temps c'est pas on ne pousse pas eu à
donner au fond d'une lingerie abusez pas
pénible rien au contraire vidéo bien au
contraire mais y avait il ya encore de
nombreux métiers avec des gens qui
commencent à travailler très tôt dont le
travail est extrêmement pénible
il est logique que les départs se fasse
plus tôt mais c'est pour ça que je pense
qu'il faut quand même oser poser la
question du système actuel est ce qu'on
a vraiment besoin d'un système à ce
point là solidaires de redistribution
est ce que finalement si on était au
choix de chacun avec une
des choses à poser sur la loire déjà
rire il très bien mais moi je suis tout
à fait en phase avec ce que dit le
premier ministre lors philippe est dit
est ce que quelqu'un peut m'expliquer
pourquoi un chauffeur de bus à marseille
prend sa retraite à 60 ans est un
chauffeur de bus parisien peut prendre
sa retraite à 53 ans ils conduisent le
même bus il ya autant de quartiers
difficiles à marseille qu'à paris il ya
autant de jets de pierres il ya autant
de la civilité il ya autant de quartier
agréable
pourquoi cette différence entre une
simple le fini fini on arrête là non ça
c'est hélas on recentre léger mars et
c'est pas entre des intellectuels et des
manuels c'est contre marseille la vie
est plus cool ça non mais c'est dénoncer
l' on voit qu'il ya une réforme évidente
à faire parce que c'est n'est pas normal
là il ya un problème les kits oui mais
très bien non très bien l'équité mais
l'équité elle va toujours vers la
situation la plus difficile du martinez
c'est exactement ce qu'il dit à me suis
dit c'est son mari qui dans l'esprit des
gens la réforme c'est quelque chose qui
complique la situation actuelle plutôt
que la meilleure vous dites voilà si si
ce qui est pourquoi il n'y a pas égalité
entre ceux qui partent à 50 ans et ceux
qui partent à 60 ans mais personne ne
propose que tout le monde parte à 50 ans
dont il propose que c'est tout le monde
passe à de bart à 60 ans
donc évidemment pour des gens il ya une
perte
bah oui on n'améliore pas leur situation
là on leur rend plus difficile plus tôt
c'est non on n'est pas chez les
bisounours
je sais bien que c'est peut-être
nécessaire mais dans la façon dont les
gens après cette situation ils ont
l'impression qu'on leur demande plus si
c'est un peu ça on va en parler on va
tomber
justement alors il ya le mouvement
c'est fait l'autre jour on a donné 35
milliards pour rembourser le déficit de
la sncf
si on les reprend dès qu'on le mettait
dans les hôpitaux est pas là pour le
coup la grandeur des hôpitaux d'une
question que la dette de 30 milliards
soit oui là je pense avoir des besoins
de votre prise mercredi et mai mais là
pour le coup je ne sais pas s'il y aura
un lien entre justement l'opinion et les
cheminots pour les hôpitaux ce tout le
monde se sent concerné parce que tout le
monde a peur de la maladie tout le monde
connaît quelqu'un qui était hospitalisé
tout le monde peut avoir eu affaire aux
urgences où il faut attendre de plus en
plus et là c'est un vrai problème non et
donc voilà la question datent pas d'il
ya trois ans et c'est vrai parce que
nous nous hélas nous les nôtres nous
avons forcément eu un moment donné j'ai
compté que nous aurons à fréquenter le
service public hospitalier
peut-être de manière beaucoup plus
grande échelle que la ratp ou la sncf
qui concerne paris n'est pas la france
et la situation des la situation des
soignants est épouvantable elle est
terrible et les c'est un service public
des monnaies et pour le coup c'est un
service public qui peut-être et est
assez différent de beaucoup d'autres je
moi je
j'estime que la priorité est sans doute
là notre cher public de l'enseignement
supérieur ne sauve pas des vies alors ça
représentait 3 % du pib
c'est rien tout ce qu'on veut et cetera
oui d'accord mais la priorité n'est pas
chez nous elle est là avec avec des
agents du service public qui sont pour
la plupart d'entre eux et chacun peut le
constater
exemplaire dévoué mais un mécanisme une
institution qui fonctionne sur le
fondement du dévouement est extrêmement
fragile n'est la preuve beaucoup avec ce
dévouement des personnels
le fait ça marche de toute façon ils
feraient leur boulot même dans des
secteurs des défilés il le fait qu'elle
un brassard c'est le font leur travail
et ils le font parfaitement fait
maintenant donc ou qu'il ya une priorité
est évidemment c'est sale ici je crois
aussi qu'on a un état qui est trop
rentrer dans la logique du
désendettement en général alors
évidemment ça devient une priorité mais
ça peut expliquer aussi cette réforme
des retraites par l'uniformisation les
états doivent devenir rentable c'est un
peu moi je pense le risque qu'on a pour
les prochaines années pour ce type de
service public c'est que évaluer tous
les services publics de la même façon et
faire rentrer tout le monde dans une
logique de l'économie n'est pas possible
au moins pour ce type de service public
là je crois qu'on peut pas raisonner
avec les concepts qu'on a actuellement
il ya une vraie question du service
public de la poste place du service
public dans les revendications des gilet
jaune
il y avait ça aussi il y avait de
l'éloignement des services publics
et c'est vrai qu'on a l'impression d'une
qu'est une dégradation du service public
depuis
alors 20 ans je ne sais pas comment on
peut la dater mais depuis quelques
années que le service public n'est plus
à la hauteur de ce que c'était avec des
infos qui qu'ils ont pourtant le mot
café c'est vrai une réplication qui
porte à dire moins de taxes plus de
services oui il ya comme un problème ni
un bon mois payer pour le service public
tant que je peux et en fonction de ce
que chacun peut moi ça ne gêne pas au
contraire une au contraire est en effet
sa supplique hospitalier sa part n'a pas
raisonné en termes de rentabilité
là le le service public n'est pas là
pour faire de l'argent il a pour rendre
un service
et c'est à la collectivité à la
solidarité nationale d'assumer mais
enfin point trop n'en faut non plus
évidemment mais c'est aussi pour ça que
je pense que politiquement l'a
apparemment peu de rapport mais la
privatisation de la française des jeux
la privatisation des aéroports de paris
me semble plutôt de bonne augure parce
que je perds je préfère que l'état
s'occupe de l'hôpital que l'état
s'occupe de l'armée que les classes
s'occupe de l'année ce qui était
vraiment un euro est ce que c'est le
rôle de l'état c'est que la française
des jeux
non est ce que c'est le
de l'état de s'occuper du duty free de
droit sinon voila je pense que là c'est
vrai qu'il ya une redéfinition plutôt
une bonne grosse part de la vérité des
fonctions régaliennes de l'état bien
trop de l'état n'est pas très
intéressant donc donc on est peut-être
sur ceux sur la bonne voie et puis juste
terminée là dessus mais j'ai écouté ce
matin en revenant il y avait un truc à
france inter était pourtant pas un
journaliste qui est pas fondamentalement
de droite thomas legrand qui parlait de
l'état de la salle et dans 67 des swazis
que ça de l'état des hôpitaux en 67 ce
que j'ignorais totalement 67 y ait pas
de chambres privées dans les hôpitaux et
il passait des interviews de 60 m de
l'époque d'un grand prof de médecine et
du nain d'une infirmière qui était
exactement on avait l'impression que
c'était aujourd'hui les infirmières qui
se plaignait mais c'est pas sûr
dévouement tout à leur écoute et on veut
bien travailler 24 heures sur 24 on a
une seule journée de repos par semaine
le professeur de médecine qui était là
en train de bien écouter on a une salle
commune de 48 ils sont 76 dedans voilà
donc on revient aussi de loin alors
c'est vrai que les trente ans quarante
ans de trucs pendant lequel sap a été
terrible mais mais voilà 67 c'est pas si
loin que ça et quant à la gauche qui
soutient le mouvement il faut dire que
les 35 heures n'ont pas facilité la
situation dans les voiles à l'université
et le malaise des étudiants un vague
malaise oui cet étudiant qui s'est
immolé évidemment ça c'est très
spectaculaire mais il ya il ya le la
question de la précarité des étudiants
c'est vrai que je disais statistiques il
ya une majorité d'étudiants qui
travaillent pour payer leurs études et
qui travaille plus qu'à mi-temps quand
même ce qu'est ce qui est quand même la
moitié mais plus de la moitié des études
travail traces canines plus que mi temps
voilà c'est ça alors je m'étais mal
classés c'est ce que je voulais dire et
c'est quand même un vrai problème c'est
un vrai problème mais il faut pas non
plus considérer que rien n'a été fait
c'est ma assez d'accord mais mais il ya
eu une prise de conscience réelle
alors qui comme souvent a été comment
dirais-je les pouvoirs publics ont pris
conscience de cela à contretemps c'est à
dire qu'on à massifier j'aime pas cette
expression enfin se consacrer
l'enseignement supérieur au début des
années 1980 la période qui précède les
années 80 c'est pour résumer 1 950 mille
étudiants en france là il y en a
aujourd'hui deux millions et demi d
atari il a fallu construire des
logements universitaires mettent en
place des systèmes de bourses un peu
plus perfectionné des restaurants
universitaires des bibliothèques etc et
des amphithéâtres et d imiter et des
antennes et des universités aux
transmissions et bien l université etc
aujourd'hui on l'est on les regroupe on
les réduit mais c'est pas assez
ça c'est très clair mais on peut pas non
plus considérer que rien n'a été fait et
d'autre part permettez moi d'ajouter au
regard de cette situation qui est
symboliquement épouvantable ce cet
étudiant qui s'immolent etc enfin se
trouve je m'arretes qu'il vous est
horrible mais on ne peut pas non plus
justifié le discours qui a été entendue
à la fac de droit de lille en début de
semaine on se languit légal
hand qui a été interdit de conférence
d'abord parce que on ne les censeurs ont
toujours tort d'où qu'ils viennent et
que les les
le syndicat solidaires qui a qui se
permet de faire une intrusion dans un
amphithéâtre de dégrader le matériel de
déchirer des bouquins et de dire
hollande assassin dans une enceinte
universitaire qui est une enceinte de
mon point de vue qui est un lieu un lieu
sacré où la liberté de parole la liberté
d'expression la liberté de pensée la
libre confrontation des opinions dans le
respect de l'autre doit pouvoir
s'exprimer s'il ya un lieu dans notre
société jouit je le dis et je le redis
vifs débats il ça doit toujours être
possible c'est un email
et donc ce que l'on voit et et jeux et
jeux jose relier sanaa ce qui se passe
depuis depuis un certain temps alors
c'est assez régulier est assez récurrent
mais ça devient très pénible et de mon
point de vue très dangereux 7
cette censure qui est le fait non plus
comme jadis des gouvernements ou de
l'état nous avons un statut très
protecteur qui de mon point de vue est
plus protecteur encore pour notre
indépendance et notre liberté que celui
des magistrats paris où nous sommes
inamori et nous ne sommes pas inspectés
nous ne sommes pas noté nous ne recevons
d'ordre de personne nous avons un statut
très protecteur et tant mieux aller c
est tant mieux en mieux et c'est le cas
dans la plupart des universités de la
dignité universités ghesquière vendredi
à l'exception bien sûr mais les entraves
à à nos libertés fondamentales
l'universitaire et au delà de citoyens
elles sont aujourd'hui portées non plus
par le pouvoir politique mais par
certains noirs de monde certaines
certaines factions de de ce type là et
c'est parfaitement insupportable où on
annule une une conférence de sylviane à
gré des pas la pire des extrémistes
scandaleux parce que elle rit de saison
de dire qu'en plus c'est symbolique mais
sérieusement c'est un beau défi
c'est une parfaite menthe insupportable
et là j'ose le dire la latitude de nos
collègues présidents d'université gless
quand même à désirer alors la cpu
conférence des présidents d'université à
faire communiquer la semaine dernière à
propos de l'affairé gazeuse qui en dix
ans mais finalement ce qui se passe
c'est qu'on reporte les événements mais
on les annule pas vraiment ce qui est
vrai sur le fond mais on a aujourd'hui
dans notre état de droit les moyens de
faire en sorte qu'une conférence qu'un
débat puisse se tenir non dépit des
menaces qui sont qui sont parfaitement
inacceptables tout cela ne doit pas ne
doit pas éluder la situation tragique de
cet étudiant la question amateurs
régularité étudiante mais ces amalgames
ces raccourcis
cette censure elle est insupportable
internet j'ai trouvé tout à fait moi je
trouve qu'on en fait peut-être un petit
peu trop sur sept alors cessé ses affres
dire ça évidemment la situation est
dramatique beaucoup d'étudiants sont
dans une situation précaire
financièrement socialement etc mais je
pense qu'on en fait un petit peu trop
sur cette précarité
moi je crois qu'il ya donc on offre dans
le cénacle universitaires des conditions
développement qui sont réels et que nous
ouvrons même beaucoup d'outils qui ne
sont absolument pas sollicitée
donc moi je j'ai le sentiment que les
mouvements universitaires bien plus que
les étudiants eux mêmes et les
mouvements étudiants là la syndication
assez rapide qu'on leur propose est un
peu dangereuse dans le sens où on a le
sentiment que c'est un âge où ils se
cherchent un petit peu et que cesser ces
différents mouvements portent des
projets très contradictoires on soutient
les gilet jaune on les soutient plus on
essaye de faire du 2d des révolutions
dans tous les sens et et moi je suis un
peu hostile à tout cela je crois que il
faut écouter les revendications qui sont
importantes de conditions de vie
mais au-delà de ça je crois qu'on
on a aujourd'hui des conditions
développement qui sont pas du tout une
crise de l'université pas du tout en
termes de propositions pas du tout en
termes d'encadrement et voilà s'ils ont
passé le temps qu'on a à détruire des
amphithéâtres à écouter ce qui est dit à
l'intérieur on pourrait en gagner
beaucoup à mon avis tout dire papa là la
section l'enseignement qui est le plus
en crise pas du tout dire
c'est aussi un choix de société un jeu
1,3 pour cent du pib
c'est un choix mais c'est un choix qui
comporte des risques
en gros sur ce sujet dont il veut juste
puisque vous parliez de violence il ya
quand même un sondage qui est assez
intéressant c'est que je crois que c'est
6% des des français ça fait à peu près 5
4 millions 5 trouve normal qu'on
s'attaque aux oublis urbain dans les
manifestations qu'on casse et la
soutiennent et casseurs ça doit donner à
peu près de la proportion d'abrutis
callen chaque pays
voilà ce qu'on a une sorte de brut y
reconnaissez vous-même gonades abrutis
ce genre de sandales à métaux pour tout
cas le peuple à trouvable russie a
trouvé qu'on les voit surgir de temps un
peu voilà alors vous le demandiez on va
pas cesser la polémique celle affaire
polanski
[Musique]
alors avant de parler évidemment il ya
la sortie du film j'accuse
je vous propose de regarder la bande
annonce et puis on parle après de tout
ce qui entoure la sortie de ce film au
nom du peuple français
premier conseil de guerre du
gouvernement militaire de paris a
reconnu le nommer dreyfus alfred
coupables du crime de haute trahison
la leçon à tirer du châtiment de dreyfus
est de montrer au monde ce que nous
faisons des traîtres
[Musique]
vous êtes désormais responsable du
renseignement cité des coudreaux que
dreyfus et pas de traîtres
je pense que nous devrions agir
rapidement dans l'intérêt de l'armée mon
dieu mon colonel de sept ans des taux
s'envolent de chefs ou suivant leurs
ordres je ne veux pas d'une autre
affaire dreyfus
ce n'est pas une autre affaire dreyfus
mon général
c'est la même
le dossier secret sur fréjus désormais
son chargeur et personne tellement on
intercepte mon courrier je suis
constamment suivi
peux-tu prouver tout cela voudrait
éviter un scandale c'est déjà un
scandale
devrait quitter paris quelque temps et
toi
j'ai l'honneur de vous présenter
monsieur emile zola quelqu'un doit
exposer toute l'histoire en tant
qu'officier d'actifs je ne peux rien
écrire là dessus vous non mais moi si
j'accuse le général mercier de s'être
rendue complice d'une des plus grande
iniquité du siècle
généralement d'avoir une étrave c'est
d'une agence de presse ou de les avoir
étouffés
j'accuse expert en écriture d'avoir fait
des rapports frauduleux
traître
quand une société on est là
elle tombe en décomposition
[Musique]
j'accuse donc de rompre au volant ce qui
qui raconte la sphère dreyfus du point
de vue du commandant puis colonel picard
qui va dire de venir à la la fin
ministre de la guerre et picard est un
antisémite
c'est à dire du jardin j'aime pas les
juifs
enfin c'est d'un antisémitisme que tu es
très français traits culturels
et pourtant contre sa hiérarchie contre
les ordres qu'il a il quand il
s'aperçoit que l affaire dreyfus a été
monté de toutes pièces il va sortir les
documents il va lui maman au péril quand
même de 2,2 au fond de sa carrière
puisqu'elle va y va mieux aussi fait
connaître la prison et il va sauver de
réfugiés alors après est ce que il pas
pour quelle raison il a fait ça des
historiens se sont plus partagés là
dessus mais c'est un c'est un excellent
film
mais voilà polluée par des accusations
nouvelles de viol contre le cinéaste par
nancy mc cain qui s'appelle volonté de
monier et on voit bien que beaucoup de
notamment de dans le milieu du cinéma
beaucoup de jeunes d'airelles qui est un
qui joue dreyfus d'ailleurs dans le film
n'est pas venue à la dernière projection
privée si je peux dire avant le
lancement du film
qu'est ce que vous en pensez en charge
un peu mais juste avant toute chose les
eut signalé un papier passionnant dans
le figaro
du 14 novembre qui raconte la position
du figaro sur l' affaire dreyfus et ses
affluents passionnant parce qu'en fait
ce que je ne savais pas du tout c'est
que le figaro a donné à l'époque trois
fautes trois fois de suite ses colonnes
à zola et a soutenu dreyfus très vite et
et puis à un moment effectivement à
arrêter au mauvais au moment où provost
ça parce que les lecteurs du figaro
était furieux la position du figaro oui
et gratter comme am abend lectorat
plutôt catholique voilà non mais c'est
incroyable parce qu'en fait ils ont ils
ont soutenu dreyfus pendant les quatre
cinquièmes de la fère et au moment où ça
allait basculer
ils ont ils ont fermé les colonnes à
zola qui du coup aller retrouver clément
sommet mais c'est marrant c'est interdit
dans l'aurore alors qu'il exècre
d'adapter mon soutien au sommet mais
c'est un point d'histoire intéressant
non alors sinon ben surpris sur polanski
il ya deux choses il ya cette
condamnation qu'il empêche d'aller aux
états unis parce que sinon il sera là il
sera embastillé va tous les pays qui ont
aidé des accords d'extradition avec les
etats-unis en fait bon vin qui
accepterait de le livrer donc ça c'est
effectivement un problème apparaît c'est
un problème effectivement c'est
scandaleux été condamné il a violé
quelqu'un il a reconnu les télés jugé
coupable ça c'est un roc un vrai
scandale
après les les accusations d des deux
nouvelles enfin les deux nouvelles
accusations
si c'est vrai c'est terrible si c'est
pas vrai c'est horrible pour lui moi se
trouve qu'il ya aussi un peu comme dans
un état de droit c'est que donc vous
quand même attendre que la justice se
prononce
d'une part avec leur présomption
d'innocence à bâle a maintenant j'ai des
rebelles et le mouvement mitu la
présomption d'innocence on ne sait même
plus ce que ça veut dire enfin je veux
dire c'est contradictoire soit en
balance son port soit on est pour la
justice mais visiblement c'est les deux
sont pas compatibles et puis là ça ne
conteste rae
peut-être qu'elles ne sont pas
contestables un d'ailleurs les mais les
paroles des accusations quand ils n'ont
aucun conseil ni devant la justice'' une
enquête
voilà il ya des prescriptions ouais ça
peut pas être ça peut peut être passé
devant la justice donc c'est vrai qu'on
est obligé de prendre pour argent
comptant les accusations absolument et
alors quelqu'un dit il ya 40 ans je
faisais du ski je me suis fait violer
par
mais si c'est vrai ce absolument henry
mais attendons peut-être que con et un
soupçon de deux ans parce que sinon
c'est monstrueux et puis alors au delà
de ça que maintenant d'aider des
fascistes féminine interdit aux gens
d'aller voir le film interdit mais on
est au delà du scandale mais tout à
l'heure vous le disiez fait qu'est ce
que c'est que ces censeurs qui série
comme ça ils ont une idée on dit alors
qu'elle manifeste quelqu'un qu'elle se
paye des des pages de pub du marquage
sera bien ça qui dit vivement
l'état finance le cinéma et il disait en
finançant le ciné vote polanski aux
finances le viol
oui mais mais bientôt bientôt il va y
avoir un comité de salut public au cnc
qui valaient alors là oui mais ça c'est
un sujet qui épate qui est un petit peu
chaud alors là non alors il faut surtout
pas mettre de l'argent là-dedans il faut
pas mettre de l'argent dans on va
interdire les films de polanski et la
télévision
alors on va interdire pourquoi on
n'interdit pas vous allez continuer
voilà il faut qu on n'interdit pas ou
dit allen a lancé pourquoi on a beaucoup
on a encore le viread et des problèmes
aussi un lobby justement on a encore le
droit de lire ces lignes on en camp de
base dans id allen n'est pas de
distribuer aux états unis notamment
mais je suis pourtant plutôt pro
américain mais je dirais que tout
heureusement je suis content de vivre en
france et pose états unis totalement
scandaleux que ce type et c'est sa
carrière soit soit fini ça les normes
cinéaste et on peut j'espère encore
l'heure actuelle en france en tout cas
faire la distinction entre une oeuvre et
son créateur
céline est une ordure mais s'aimer mais
mort à crédit est un chef-d'oeuvre voilà
bon bah c'est anne servane bezina je
pense que je vais tout désigné pour être
contre tout contre jean charles
là la question à mon avis et et p très
vite des voiliers je suis d'accord avec
toi sur la question de l'oeuvre le
boycott du film ya des costumières des
éclairages il ya des gens qu'on
travaille et il ya des acteurs sont
formidables dans ce film un sujet
passionnant il ya un très bon
réalisateur ça on le met de côté
néanmoins sur le principe de la culture
du viol sur la sphère adèle haenel
moi je crois pas qu'on soit complètement
a même logique que le mythe ou parce que
j'ai l'impression que on est en train
aujourd'hui d'essayer de parler d'un
d'une affaire du siècle en quelque sorte
avec ces procès climatique etc
on essaye maintenant de changer les
mentalités alors je suis d'accord avec
toi sur les principes de justice sur les
droits de la défense sur la présomption
d'innocence sur le secret de
l'intruction on en a déjà parlé de cette
société bfm qui devient un peu
dangereuse mais est ce qu'il ne faut pas
finalement qu'un changement des
mentalités précède le changement des
législations ça à moi c'est plutôt mon
point de vue et je pense que sur le
changement des mentalités c'est
important que la parole se libère alors
on l'a vu malheureusement avec balance
t'emporte il ya évidemment beaucoup
d'excès mais est-ce que ça n'est pas
préférable de mettre sur le devant de la
scène les problèmes se défendre aussi
voilà parce qu'il ya une pendant
longtemps les femmes qu'ils visitent et
disert il fait violer par même les
policiers enfin personne n'est content
exactement judiciairement c'est encore
quelque chose qui est très lourd
c'est pas que c'est pas facile
exactement et s'éteint c'est un
processus qui psychologiquement
mériterait d'être mieux analyser c'est
là que peut-être les médias ont une
forme de responsabilité à avoir aussi
parce que exploiter les souffrances des
gens pour faire du chiffre
c'est évidemment dramatique mais je
pense que psychologiquement
voilà justement des spécialistes des
psychiatres des psychologues ont humilié
ce domaine et il ya une parole qui se
libère avec le temps aussi donc c'est
peut-être bien que des événements qui
sont juridiquement prescrits soit quand
même mis sur le devant de la scène qu'on
ait des femmes qui osent parler le
milieu du cinéma étant justement
particulièrement particulièrement
exposés alors après qu'ils aient dents
on sentit ou pas est-ce que c'est pas
facile un petit peu aujourd'hui de faire
ça néanmoins sur polanski
moi je crois qu'il ya un moment où où le
soutien doit quand même franchement
s'arrêter on a on a on a des idées des
poursuites qui s'arrêtent n'allez pas
voir le film mais laissez-nous allez le
voir c'est tout je n'ai pas dit ça me
faire dire ce qu'elle n'a pas dit mais
passionnant mais je pense qu'il ya
peut-être un moment où il faut que les
pouvoirs publics français osent prendre
leurs responsabilités en déjà en
initiant des procédures quand il en a
besoin en écoutant ce qui a été dit est
peut-être bon alors l'extradition pour
motifs politiques je veux bien mais il
ya un moment où la protection ce
monsieur devient quand même profondément
problématique avec ce qu'il peut faire
sachant qu'en plus si on me laisse
tourner étant donné que il ya toujours
ce parallèle avec le pygmalion c'est ce
qu'a fait exactement le réalisateur dans
la sphère adèle haenel
il utilise aussi cette aura artistique
pour avoir une forme d'abus de position
dominante sur une jeune femme est
apparemment en plus plus elles sont
jeunes plus ça peut être risqué donc lui
donner les moyens malheureusement de
réaliser ce pour quoi il a un talent
c'est aussi le l'aider dans son vis donc
il ya quand même une mesure à trouver là
dans l'essence il pas mon prof de droit
que je devrais dire ça mais occupons
nous de la faire
adèle haenel qui n'est pas prescrite et
où il peut y avoir une instruction et
peut y voir un procès mais leur jugement
à porter l affaire devant la justice
cet événement sont servis aux problèmes
aussi enfin qu'on avait beaucoup abordé
avec celle de louis ferdinand céline
notamment est-ce qu'il faut séparer
l'oeuvre et l'autre pour moi afin de
trouver ça dans tous les sens et chacun
son opinion
mais évidemment l'oeuvre n'est pas
l'auteur même si elle est l'oeuvre est
une partie de l'auteur et l'acteur n'est
pas nécessairement non plus le citoyen
sans succès d'ailleurs polanski dire
j'ai tourné j'accuse parce que je suis
une sorte de circuit si c'est ça c'est
un voile et je le crois pas jean-charles
le disait moi j'aime liberté de
spectateurs je suis libre ou pas afin je
suis libre d'aller voir ou pas une
oeuvre qui jusqu'à présent n'a pas été
proscrite interdite censuré que ça géant
heureusement encore et cette liberté je
vais pouvoir l'utiliser et ceci dit je
ne suis pas complices je ne suis pas un
criminel je ne suis pas violeur en
allant acheter une place de cinéma pour
voir ce film je n'ai pas à me substituer
à l'institution justice qui est seule
compétente pour statuer sur ces
questions-là alors par ailleurs et vous
l'avez dit elle charlène entièrement
raison enfin tous touchent classe en
vivent
enfin la parole sur la fin on porte un
regard un peu plus avec l'acuité
nécessaires sur ces questions qui se
posent fondamental de quelques mois
quelques excès quand on voit ce pauvre
pierre joxe alors quelqu'un près de 90
ans et que maintenant on va accuser pas
ce qu'il a dit a eu à une de ces
stagiaires qu'elle avait de belles
fesses ce que est ce que tout ça n'a pas
un peu loin c'est vrai que si vous
voulez tuer quelques jeunes filles vous
l'accusez 2 voilà il l'a fait et bien
fait la fête mais s'il l'a pas fait
c'est vrai que médiatique dont il de vos
étudiants de vous êtes vous accusent de
leur innocence a fini d et c'est fini
mais en dix minutes vous serez relatives
à la situation américaine ont pas
l'ascenseur avec un quotidien tous les
portes sont toujours ouvertes où c'est
vrai que c'est ça cela dit la situation
américaine finissent toujours par
arriver ici et on prend ce qui est pire
cauchemar session finalement pourquoi
on veut collectiviser la morale un peu
moins c'est ça qui me gêne profondément
et tu parlais d'extrémistes se féminise
jeu pas forcément d'accord avec ton
terme mais tu me le permettra
néanmoins je crois que c'est vrai que il
ya maintenant cette idée que il faut
boycotter les gens il faut manger de
telle et telle manière les boucheries
c'est mal les petits chatons c'est bien
et c'est dommage je pense que la morale
c'est quelque chose de profondément
individuelles toutes les législations de
moralisation sont fumeuses ne servent à
rien il faut le dire
néanmoins quant à savoir si on peut
vraiment séparer une oeuvre de son
auteur moi je crois que si on étudie là
aussi le processus psychologique s'est
pas complètement possible on a besoin
d'admirer quand même la personne pour
laquelle on a on a on a envie d'avoir un
sentiment affectif de salon wii est ce
qu on a forcément envie d'aller d'aller
se confronter à l'oeuvre de quelqu'un
qu'on n'a pas envie d'admirer moi moi je
ne supporte pas personnellement
d'entendre chanter bertrand quentin
parce que j'ai saisi ma gens viennent et
encore que sa vous diront lui au moins
il appuyé voilà mais bon est encore payé
voilà les choses si on me met le feu il
ya un besoin qui peut être différente
pour chacun moi j'ai du mal certains y
arrivent et voilà ça dépend à mon avis
du fort intérieur et je pense qu'il faut
essayer d'arrêter de dire qu' il y a des
choses qu'il faut des choses qu'il ne
faut par l'achat qu'un voit midi à sa
porte sur cette question néanmoins là
dessus je te rejoins complètement sur
les poursuites sur sur ce qu'il faut
jury 10,6 et de cette question il ya
évidemment une question à se poser deux
sociétés et sur ce monsieur peut être
aussi en arriver à sa propre
responsabilité à ce que voilà la voie de
son petit diable fait que les sociétés
ont besoin de boucs émissaires et on est
aussi non non ce phénomène maintenant on
va peut-être passer à 1
débat aussi il y eut cette marche contre
l'islamophobie c'est le débat ce qu'il
fallait marcher ou pas alors oui on a
bien vu que beaucoup de gens même qu'ils
étaient favorables dire après tout on
peut laisser des gens portait le voile
était des rats il faut pas stigmatiser
les musulmans même beaucoup de gens et
notamment à gauche on était très gênée
par rapport à cette marche non ya trois
valises et homme politique veut c'est
tout à l'honneur du foehn enfants du
personnel politique français tout le
monde s'est abstenu de participer à
cette manifestation
mise à part jean luc mélenchon et ses
sbires
allez encore et encore la france a
soumis deux étaient très divisés sur ce
sujet très très divisés sauf s il ya
beaucoup de députés qu'ils y font pas
les bons filons quand les gens me disent
qu'ils ont quand même laissé ça parce
qu'il ya dix mois cfoot les dimanches il
a signé il avait faute au moment des
faits tout à fait dommage que la
sénatrice france insoumise qui a passé
toute la manifestation à côté d'une
petite fille de 5 ans à avec une étoile
jaune greffer sur son manteau voilà ce
il y aura pas de météo france qui est
qui était directrice de recherche au
cnrs et chargé de l est les spécialistes
de l'histoire du judaïsme des idées donc
elle sait ce que c'est
mains sur la tête de la manifestation je
crois que tous les politiques se sont
abstenus dont il aurait dû tous le faire
notamment parce qu'on ne maîtrisait pas
bien qui était derrière et je pense que
c'est tout rires je l'avais lu contre
lucie bilodeau le risque est quand même
un mouvement fait très lié aux frères
musulmans athées dort bien fait d'accord
avec cela ouais c'est que d'autres est
malheureusement pour le sujet qui est
qu'est ce qui peut amener à mieux
respecter le vivre ensemble et à parler
une question collective et de nation
c'est une bonne chose
néanmoins voilà c'est toujours le risque
avec une manifestation c'est de savoir
qui finalement l'a alors qu'istres et là
on était franchement pas sûr du début de
la fin l'initiative
donc je pense qu'il aurait fallu vivre
ensemble fait de hurler allah akbar dans
les rues de paris soit quelque chose qui
va faire progresser le vivre ensemble
je parlais de récupération et je pense
que justement elle a été récupérée et
que c'est dommage mais sur le sujet
lui-même je parlais du sujet je pense
que le sujet en tant que tel on
gagnerait quand même un seul posées
notamment sur la sur la question de leur
public de savoir comment est-ce qu'on
peut arriver à a
vivre avec une pluralité de religion et
avec des personnes qui se sentent
également respecter est également
représentée en arrivant à poser même des
questions qui fâchent
est-ce qu'on peut discuter de la
question du voile aujourd'hui sans que
ça devienne nationale et tout le monde
donc vous des questions comment est ce
qu'on peut vivre avec toutes ces
religions simplement en regardant la
religion comme un truc intime et
personnelle en n'en faisant pas étalage
24 heures sur 24
cette réaction est tout seul et les pas
de voile pas ne veut pas de signe sans
se faire pas de pas de kippa sur la tête
pas de papa de crucifix autour du cou de
2,3 mètres de circonférence voilà c'est
tout sa capacité mais c'est vrai que
beaucoup de juifs
quelques encore aujourd'hui seront dit
on dit on peut c'est compliqué de vivre
en france aujourd'hui des musulmans
peuvent le dire aujourd'hui c'est vrai
que ça pose aussi un problème la laïcité
c'est aussi le respect des religions non
vallée de la liberté l'auto certes et
c'est l'article 1er de la loire et qui
d'ailleurs est constitutionnalisée c'est
le le respect pour chacun de pratiquer
la religion de son choix ou de n'en
pratiquer aucune
c'est comme un sentiment que
l'antisémitisme est quand même beaucoup
plus le basé sur le projet d'un groupe
enfin si on peut pas dire le mot race
m'enfin de deux petites vis n'est pas
l'antisémitisme l affaire dreyfus pas la
démo sujet précédent ces accords donc
après une question mais s'est vu la
celerio 6 me suis senti beaucoup de
colombiens pour évidemment je peux du
tout il est ce qui s'était passé à
créteil
il ya même plus d'actes antisémites que
d'actes anti musulman je dis ça peut
avoir que la religion mais n'oublions
pas les deux choses religion manière
d'être manière de vivre toutes les
questions écrites à mon avis d'être
posée et on a on à moi je ne vois en
tant que et toi aussi bien sûr en tant
que chargé d'enseignement en droit
administratif
les conseils d'ordre public d'intérêt
général aujourd'hui sont plus en plus
marginalisés ostracisé parce qu'on a du
mal d'aidés dès qu'on en arrive à a posé
la question du fonds commun finalement
on se rend compte qu'il n'y en a plus on
est en train de se diviser
je trouve que le discours de gérard
collomb en quittant ministère de
l'intérieur en disant qu'ils qu'il a
peur pour l'avenir de la république et
quand même quelque chose dont on n'a pas
forcément pris la mesure à l'heure
actuelle c'est que il est impossible de
retrouver à part dans les moments de
coupe du monde et encore avec la ferme
et nahla on a pu avoir ce plaisir
pendant quatre journées donc servis
voilà c'est bon ça semble allons-y abbas
et loba le seppuku alors la boue la
voilà la mort de raymond poulidor
évidemment non ça ça doure se
rassemblent tous quand même non alors
moi je n'ai pas connu mais ça continue
un peu triste de tout ça m'a choisi
entendu parler de l'image non ces sites
c'est vrai que cette histoire c'est
extraordinaire parce que non seulement
il n'a jamais gagné le mali jeunes là
j'avais porté ce qu'il ya des dix
émissions des fêtes avec lui il
racontait qu'un jouet l'année la voir et
c'est un monaco et est là il y avait
deux tours de piste il avait dit
malheureusement j'ai sprinté au premier
tour
je crois que je ne savais pas qu'il y
avait deux tours c'est connu c'est pas
le corrézien
j'ai crevé mais ça reste un peu le on
dit on en parlait tout à l'heure le
l'éternel second c'est ça qu'on l'aimé
bien et parce que c'est le brave type
qui venaient du fond de sa campagne dans
corrèze etc
et puis qui a été porté sur le devant de
la scène mais il a quand même gagné
énormément de compétition il n'a jamais
gagné le tour de france c'est vrai on
avait l'impression d'ailleurs qu'il
était plus de 3e de 2e 6 voire même au
3e c'était un peu un peu le chat noir
allait lui arriver tout le temps des
trucs époux freddy hilton sénia s'ils
sont sûrs anctil après y'a mère 189 pas
mal d'argent c'est quand même le premier
s'est bien passé je lisais dans le
papier qui est écrit sur lui dans
l'équipe continue des beats et 1 c'est
un amateur 1 il ya un type qu'il repère
comme ça dans une dans une course
cycliste qui dit survivants le langage
et comme comme processus est donc ils
arrivent à négocier avec monsieur magne
s'étaient quittés auvergnats je crois et
lui est fait eelv et limousin eh ben il
s'est pas laissée faire du tout c'est à
dire qu'il n'a pas pris le salaire
débutant d'un il a négocié comme un
dingue alors qu'il n'était rien du tout
c'est quand même donc divin il y avait
c'est vrai qu'il ya un rapport à
l'argent mais c'est vrai dans mes 7 7 7
ou plus la popularité donc comme dirait
blondin sous la rétine avec une polarité
les ouïes d'aidé de la france qui
n'aiment pas gagné elle a changé un peu
dans celle là ou pas je ne sais pas moi
c'est en tout cas monsieur plus âgé que
charlène mais j'ai pas non plus connu ce
pas un intime de poulidor donc si je
m'étais un peu plus âgés mais moi ce que
ça me rappelle surtout au delà de ses
performances c'est que c'est aussi
l'époque des grands écrivains qui
écrivent et très bien sur le cyclisme
soir en et fallait face de tout petit
plus dans la blonde 1 qui était quand
même des gens qui adorent et et qui
écrivait très bien sur le sport et voilà
c'est peut-être aussi moi c'est
peut-être ça que je regrette plus que
puisque tout parce qu'après bon c'est
dur c'est dommage dans la sortie de
l'âge etc
mais c'est effectivement cette époque
qui disparaît cette façon de voir les
choses
cette façon de les raconter
effectivement on est on est loin des
chaînes d'info tout continue en 30
secondes il dira tiens machin a pris son
vélo et la cour il a gagné damballa les
types blandin il faisait doux soyez sur
chaque étape du tour de france
moi je veux dire c'était fabuleux quand
il pouvait quand comme l'alcool ne m'a
pas séparer les deux
naldo si elle allait l'empêcher assez
peu de temps encore je crois qu'il y
avait je crois que les chartes ic ir
écrivait parfois des valable qu'il peut
y avoir quelques trucs à mettre en
oeuvre un journaliste de l'afp
je crois que ça démontre aussi c'est
qu'on ne serait ce que par ce visage là
c'est sait qu'on peut être heureux sans
être gagnon et peut-être que ce qui
explique un petit peu le malaise des
étudiants aujourd'hui enfin moi je le
perçois de saveurs plus dans sa jeunesse
et qu'il y avait un peu ce qu'il ya un
petit peu de compétition dans tout il
faut être le meilleur le plus beau avoir
les plus belles vacances les réseaux
sociaux mines beaucoup notre notre
capacité à être heureux facilement et je
pense que la voilà on a une cure de type
de fonctionnement distinctes il expliqué
il buvait du champagne baiser top et
personne ne trouve à redire si ce nouvel
an tamoul leader et son entrain et son
empreinte carbone comme un rapace est
vrai que c'était un temps béni et bien
c'est sur ce mot vive la saucisse de
vernis que nous permet dans cette
émission
merci à bezina stéphane rousseau et jean
charles lajoie dis à très vite pour un
nouveau pas
[Musique]